talk to me about a debate that you're
leading in the commons and what you're
calling for
well thank you kay for giving me the
opportunity to talk about the detention
of people with autism and learning
disabilities under the mental health act
there's still about 2 000 people 200 of
which are children who are being
detained uh in our system uh by using a
piece of legislation that's now the
thick end of 40 years
of age these are people who actually
don't in many instances have what i
think we would regard as a mental health
condition they are they have a lifelong
condition most notably autism
and in recent weeks we've heard some
really harrowing cases tony hickman's
case was been reported widely in the
media and patient a
as well another uh concerning case about
people who are being detained in many
cases for many many years you know five
ten fifteen even twenty years
in detention and confinement away from
their families
with a a very poor quality of
life and it seems to me in 2022
we shouldn't be accepting the sort of
conditions that um we thought we'd um uh
got rid of a generation ago and and i
think it's vital that
i uh raise these issues in the house of
commons with the government to press
them to implement the policy that they
themselves have agreed on which is to
move away from this frankly rather
barbaric practice
and to do more to give support to people
in the community where they belong
rather than being detained under a very
old piece of law that needs reform but
now is the time for action i'm going to
be pushing the government to get on with
the job not just of law reform but
actually of increasing and improving
community facilities across the country
we need the health service and our
social care services to help step up
here to end this
frankly barbaric practice the average
length of state is five years for
somebody that's autistic so we're
talking about somebody that just
experiences the world differently you
know i'm not sick i'm not broken i don't
need to be treated we don't need to be
treated uh we certainly don't need to be
caged and subject to the sort of
inhumane and degrading treatment but
that's far too often what's happening um
and as he said there's 2 000 people
still detained in hospital and it's
always a worry that i have you know that
there is no community support
um and so often what happens which which
happened in my case is something that's
a social event happens like my brother
died and i had a baby you know two very
ordinary
things that that might happen to people
and i simply needed a bit of
occupational therapy a bit of speech and
language and and some psychotherapy
might have cost the taxpayer you know
five thousand pounds but what happened
instead of getting that support was that
um i was sent to a a hospital you know
one of them was hundreds of miles away
from my home my i was handcuffed my legs
were tied together i was put into a cage
the car looked like you know a dog van
and i was driven to a hospital and then
i was just subject to routine restraint
seclusion and segregation and your
viewers might be thinking well gosh well
she must have been you know
and sort of you know very distressed and
upset and angry and that's that's
exactly right and i think what happens
for autistic people is most people in
the public know we need routine we need
structure we need predictability we need
familiarity and of course psychiatric
hospitals are the exact opposite of that
so in themselves they exacerbate the
more troubling features of autism which
causes us to feel distress which results
in restraint which results in seclusion
and which results in in long-term
segregation so i don't think we can call
these hospitals these specialist
hospitals supportive i had to escape so
i i took a a boat to france and i i flew
into
dubai and then into lagos um in nigeria
and from there you know that that's how
i rebuilt my life and
you know the interesting thing is that
as soon as i left you know um i wasn't
suffering the sensory overload i wasn't
suffering the cognitive overload you
know i made my environment familiar and
i was fine and working again
as a teacher in a prestigious british
curriculum school within six weeks of my
escape and they had sectioned me for a
further year
so although you know my my case uh it
might seem extreme it really isn't
extreme it's really actually the norm a
social event occurs no supports given in
the community and we're locked up in
these these institutions and you know
many of us don't get out tony hickman
20-plus years you know patient a you
know in a long-term segregation suite i
was in one of those i had a mattress on
the floor i was fed on the floor my food
was cold because it took four hours to
get to me because you know because of
staff changeovers they're really not
befitting this treatment of a of a
civilized society